with former Jedi Ahsoka running around
with her own Disney plus series we
decided to change up our regular secret
lab chess skin to keep in theme inherit
the laku pattern of one of the best
characters in the Star Wars Universe on
your secret lapchair this skin is
specially designed for the 2022 Titan
Evo and it's incredibly easy to slip on
remove the current skin before you start
of course if you're new with your skins
these covers transform your classic
Titan evil Chairs into a symbol of a
character faction or franchise you love
follow the instructions here slippery
slip there clickety clack and Anakin's
your master May the iconic Snips
Commander Tano and gray Jedi of our time
Grace our homes and inspire you to press
on and fight harder and smarter in your
day-to-day May the force be with you
always